well meantime here at home a local  non-profit helping grandparents who are  raising grandchildren received some  national exposure recently joyce eatman  runs the non-profit grants for grants  here in southern nevada now she was  featured on the kelly clarkson show just  last week and since that appearance  eatman says grandparents from all over  the country have called her asking for  help  i was so happy and pleased with channel  late and the local support we get and  and you know it's always a big help when  the media helps uh what happens people  that need our help find us and then  people that can't help us find us so  it's always a wonderful situation but  getting that call was really exciting  they do great work we have more  information on grants for grants on our  website at 8newsnow.com